Welcome to Ear Biscuits.
The podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett.
This week at The
Roundtable of Dim Lighting,
we're talking about getting older.
But it's not gonna be boring.
Getting older.
Don't worry.
We're gonna talk about the
process of growing older,
what we are enjoying about that
and what we're finding
to be not so enjoyable
and it's not just gonna
be talking about joints
that are going bad and stuff like that.
I mean there may be.
Oh really,
that's all I got.
There may be a tad of that.
But I think it's just
as we are, I don't know.
Are we cresting middle age?
Well I mean you're just
now getting settled into 44
as of the release of this episode.
I don't know what middle age is anymore
because I mean the life
expectancy has changed.
It's actually gone down a little bit.
Okay, well.
In the past couple of years.
Well then yeah I feel like
this is the middle age.
We're in our middle ages.
So things that are changing emotionally,
things that we're
learning about ourselves,
et cetera, et cetera.
But I thought a good
thing we could start with
s the fact that we recently
went to a concert together
with our wives.
Yeah we did.
We went to see Lord Huron.
Lord Huron.
In the Hollywood Forever Cemetery.
You can go.
Shout out to Lord Huron.
I'm a huge fan.
And then we saw him in the cemetery
which the vibe kind of fits
a cemetery vibe, it's like.
The vibe of their music?
A little bit.
Yeah I mean I wouldn't say it's creepy
but there's some haunting,
there's a haunting aspect to it.
For sure.
Like a Western haunted type thing.
Yeah and we are in the West.
That I like.
And that the reverb only
makes it more haunting
but I had never been to the
Hollywood Forever Cemetery.
Well I'd seen a movie there
because they will show
movies there in the same spot
that they do the concert
which is that big lawn
and there's a giant,
I think it's actually maybe a mausoleum.
Yeah.
That we're.
So they will project a movie.
I call them dead people drawers.
They will project a movie onto the
dead people drawer building.
Oh.
But then Lord Huron just
stood right in front of it,
on a stage.
With no, it's the first
time I've been to a concert
where I was that far away
and there was no screen.
It's not, it's just about the sounds man.
And the ambience.
And there's no,
it's a cemetery that has
not been made into a place
to play music.
So the only light is
coming from the stage.
Did you notice that?
So walking out of there it was like,
I mean when we were packing up,
you turned on your iPhone light.
That's right, yeah.
Just to find your stuff.
And there were, we got there kind of late.
We were at the back of the main lawn area
and then there's a walking path
and on the other side of that
there's a bunch of graves
and when we turned to leave I was like,
I realized that that had been filled in
and there were people
just lounging on graves.
Yeah, right.
Checking out the concert.
I don't know if you're
supposed to do that.
I mean some people believe
you shouldn't walk.
They're none the wiser.
Walk across a grave.
But I would've thought
that maybe it would've been.
Just lounging.
There would've been a sign that says,
"Don't lounge on the graves."
But maybe they just thought
that people would know that.
Yeah, it seems like
something you kind of know.
But I mean when the place
is full and you're there.
You gotta.
Where else you gonna go?
You gotta prop up somewhere.
But when we parked,
I got the special ticket to park inside
which I didn't know that meant just like,
as parking along with the gravestones
as if I was going to a graveside service.
They're directing us all the way through.
We got to kind of see
a lot of the graveyard.
There's some famous people buried there.
The most recent of which that I know of,
Chris Cornell I was just reading about.
I wish we would've found
his gravestone.
Really?
But the thing that is
also significant about it
that we learned is that the
Hollywood Forever Cemetery
is also a place where people
who don't have the means
to maybe be buried, to
have a gravestone at all
can be buried.
And I don't know exactly
how that process works
but I just know that they're,
yeah there's some famous people
and it's been around for a long time
but there's also some people
who don't have the means
for that kind of burial.
Who get these really awesome grave plots.
And the thing that we noticed
as we parked the car and
we took the scenic route
walking through these gravestones
in order to get the theater location,
well the concert location.
The lawn.
Pretty much all of them,
I wanna say at least
90% of the gravestones
had an etching of the person.
Like a photo.
Sometimes more than
an etching.
Photorealistic etching.
Sometimes you're saying a photo.
Like a printed photo almost.
Of the dead person's face.
Sometimes in color.
Really impressive.
A little creepy.
I mean I kind of thought as I
was walking by some of them,
you know when you're walking
by a painting it's like,
"Is she watching me?"
But I think that's just a principle of
if the.
Two dimensions.
If the subject is looking
at the camera lens
or the simulated camera
lens of a artistic painting.
They are technically following you.
Yeah, whenever you stand
they're gonna be looking at you
and that doesn't mean they're a ghost.
That just means it's a painting.
It's just how physics works.
Or a photo.
But in a normal cemetery,
maybe like you know,
if you're going down Highway
55 on the way to Angier
from Fuquay-Varina.
Yeah.
I'm just gonna use that
as a normal cemetery.
Yeah.
There might be
a couple of people who
have paid a little extry.
It's like oh he got his face.
Got his face on there.
But like you said, almost everyone,
at least in the section that
we were walking had their photo
and then that started a conversation.
I think that Christy or Jessie,
somebody pointed it out.
They were like, "It's interesting
that most of these people
"have chosen to have a photo
of them in their old age."
Presumably the last good portrait
that they had taken of them
before they died.
Yeah.
And there's a few people
and I would say a much smaller percentage
had their peak physical prime photo.
"Oh when I was 25 years old
or when I was 35 years old
"and now I died when I'm 90,
"but you see my
35-year-old self up there."
And that started the conversation
about what photo we
would have on our grave.
Well first of all I
have made the decision,
I'm not gonna get photo on my gravestone.
I mean it.
I didn't know,
I didn't how awesome of
an opportunity this was.
Now you said because you're
planning on getting cremated
which I am also that
there is no gravestone.
Yeah that's what I thought.
Is that true?
Is it just an urn
and that's it?
I mean you just.
First of all, I think I'm
leaning towards being cremated
but I think that's bad for the environment
and from way back in the day when we did
the Bury Me Naturally commercial,
that's the name of the company
that produces biodegradable
cardboard boxes
that you're buried in
and the worms come in
and the maggots come in
and they make you one with the earth.
And you also in the process,
you do not get embalmed.
Yeah.
So this,
it's a quick burial.
And then.
You better hope you die close to home
and we can plan your funeral really fast.
I think they swap.
I just kind of assume
you're gonna die first.
Am I right
in remembering that
after X number of years
of decomposition,
they can then bury somebody
else in the same spot?
I think that's true after awhile.
I mean it's definitely true in general.
They had to be buried longer than I was.
Just a quick plug,
if you wanna watch me get buried alive,
you can find that old
episode of Commercial Kings.
I know it's available on iTunes.
Amazon Duo.
And Amazon streaming as well
depending on what country you're in.
Yeah, we got.
That was the pilot episode.
I got buried alive and then we also
made a commercial for a guy
who picked up people's trash.
Yeah.
Pretty awesome.
Heavy hill.
So I don't think.
I don't like the idea of a gravestone.
I mean of all the people
that have been buried,
like I said that day,
the last time, the only
time I'd visit a gravestone
is for the graveside service.
As much as I love my
relatives that have passed on
and maybe it's a function,
I don't think it's a function
of living in California.
I think even if I was local, I don't know.
I just don't, something
about, I guess my beliefs.
I just don't think I need to go there
in order to reconnect with
somebody or pay homage?
I haven't found myself
being motivated to do that.
I don't know, maybe it'll be different.
When my mom passes away,
maybe I'll be motivated to go there
and commune with her.
I really, but I.
So it, but at this point in my life,
I guess because I, I
don't have any connection
or like ongoing experiences
at talking to a person
at the gravestone like
they do in the movies.
I actually just thought that's
something they do in movies.
Well go to a grave, go to a cemetery
and see how many people are showing up.
Because there's quite a few, I don't.
I haven't done it because
anyone that I was close to
in terms of my grandparents,
they're all buried in Georgia.
So.
And it's not.
I never lived,
I feel like if I lived in the town
with the grave site of
someone that I loved,
I would go to it.
You're totally right.
Yeah.
That you don't have to
go to it in order.
I'm second-guessing
all this though because I'm.
It's so ceremonial.
I just think that.
It's the most tangible
expression of their lives.
Yeah.
Or their presence that you can achieve.
It's like the body that they inhabited,
whatever your belief system is.
Is in there.
Or the body that they were,
that's as close as I can get to it.
And if you just have the urn in your,
even if you just keep it in
your house on your mantle piece,
it's gonna be harder to make an occasion
of communing in reverence.
Maybe on the dead relative's birthday
you'll take the urn down
and you'll look at it
and say something but
you're still in your house
and you're like, "Okay
now I'm gonna put it back
"and I'm gonna do the rest of my life."
But when you have to get in a vehicle,
drive to a grave,
walk or drive to the
gravestone and sit there
and have one of those cinematic moments,
it actually seems very much up my alley
to err on the side of
over-dramatizing things.
Yeah.
And by the way,
I think this is a middle
aged thing for me.
As I was talking about
Lily leaving for college
and how I tended to be, I was
pretty dramatic about that.
You know, now I'm rethinking
if I want a gravestone.
As we're talking about it right here.
What about a drawer?
Have you thought about that?
I think the drawers are really expensive.
Yeah, that's.
And also, all you get is a
drawer with your name on it.
But then you're right on the other side
of that drawer.
It's like I could yank this thing out
and I could see what's left.
But with a gravestone you
can go, you can go up.
You know?
I mean there was somebody out there
that had a literal.
What do you mean,
you can go up?
The gravestone can be really tall.
Oh, like a monument.
And so there's really,
there's really no limit.
There probably is some sort of ordinance
but we saw one guy who had a Roman column
that was part.
Yes.
That had partially carved out of the stone
and it was like at least 11 feet tall.
It was sculpted in such a
way to look like a ruin.
Yeah.
That was cool.
It was actual ruins.
Well see, this is where the
Enneagram 3 in me comes out
because I'm actually thinking about
how impressive my gravestone could be.
Like current me is thinking about
the potential of winning
the cemetery competition.
People who.
I know that it
makes no sense.
People who don't know you,
you want them to come to your gravestone
just to look at the stone.
I'm thinking about the
experience that somebody can have
because this is a very McLaughlin thing
that my dad and my
brother and my mom and I
and really just my
brother and my dad and I
because my mom doesn't really partake
in this particular thing.
We're to visit a cemetery,
what would the conversation
devolve into very quickly?
Who has the best gravestone right?
And my dad would be like,
"Well that guy's got a column, he wins."
Yep.
It's like we would,
we would just, that's what the
conversation would morph into
is like well this guy paid a lot of money.
He's got a full color thing
and that's kind of what we did.
We were doing it for
entertainment purposes
and that's why we would be doing it
but then once you start
talking about that you're like,
"Well what am I gonna do?"
'Cause I am on team cremation right now.
Okay.
And I do understand the
environmental impact.
Not from my individual cremation
but the collective cremation right?
But can I do some sort of
carbon recapture or something
on myself?
What if they could carbon recapture me
and then they could also take
that and do something with it.
I don't know if there's,
there's gotta be other ways.
Like a high time, high desiccation rate
kind of a thing where it's,
you're not burning you,
they're just drying you out
and then they're just, like a porter.
Like a jerky?
Yeah like turn you into jerky
and then turn you into a mortle
and pestle?
Desk jerky.
I said mortle and pestle.
Mortar.
Immortal and pestle.
Okay so we're gonna be freeze dried and
then crumbled into something.
Yeah I wanna be,
I wanna be crumbled for the environment.
If you freeze dried and crumbled,
you can still make out some stuff.
Oh there's some hair on that piece.
You know what I'm saying?
That could be.
Yes.
Yeah.
Oh this might,
this could be a nipple.
That could be an interesting
thing for your kids
to have to sort through.
Versus just this nondescript ashes
that could be a cow.
It's like, oh there's dad's nipple.
Freeze dried nipple, let's
throw that into the Kafue River
'cause that's another thing.
I am interested in cremation
because I want to scattered.
Smothered and covered.
But, I don't even know why.
So you're gonna buy
a really fancy headstone
and no part of your remains
are gonna be there?
No, no no no no.
I think, part of me will be.
Maybe the gonads 'cause if I'm gonna,
if I'm going to,
"Here lies Rhett McLaughlin's gonads,
"freeze-dried gonads."
Gross.
Maybe they'll be in a jar.
There's probably lots of rules about this
and we're probably violating
them in theory here.
Yeah, all I know is that
I didn't like the idea of a picture
because it's very, it's very committal.
If you're a famous
person, then the moment.
I guess if you die later in life,
well after the peak of your fame,
I would think that you would want the,
what most people know you,
that peak fame picture.
What picture do you want in the paper?
What picture do you want in the obituary?
What picture do you want?
I mean, I don't know.
If we're still relevant,
maybe there'll be an article
about that.
I just don't want
the conversation,
I just don't know that
we're famous enough.
Maybe we are.
You'd get a.
I think if one of us died,
we might trend on Twitter.
Well, I.
Probably for the
first time ever.
But I think, yes.
That might be what it takes.
Yeah, but I'm.
You wanna go for it?
You wanna experiment?
I'm really, no.
Because I'm thinking
about dying in old age.
You're definitely not
gonna trend on Twitter
in your old age.
What part,
what would my face on my gravestone be
because the last thing I
want people talking about is
what I looked like when I died.
It's like,
"Oh man, that's what he
looked like in his old age?"
I remember him from 30
years earlier you know?
I don't want that to be the conversation.
Oh wow, he really got old.
Well it kind of figures that he died,
you know kind of?
It depends on how
old you get.
Man he was ugly.
He really changed.
If you're talking like Kirk Douglas old,
man that man was old looking you know?
Yeah and so his picture on his gravestone
is like Spartacus.
But if Michael Douglas were to pass away
and you saw current Michael
Douglas you'd be like,
"That's an old man but ah,
it's a good looking guy."
I mean if it were him,
I think I would want Catherine Zeta-Jones
on my gravestone too.
Just to make it more interesting.
And like a clarification
that she's not buried there.
Yet.
We were just married.
So, look at her on this gravestone.
It's a lot better than looking
at old Michael Douglas.
Which isn't bad in and of itself.
I'm not getting the
picture is what I'm saying
but if I do.
I think if you.
It's gonna be of, I think it's
gonna be my Velma haircut.
You're going back to
haircut like circa 2010?
Yeah you remember our peak?
Well that is a conversation I wanna have
and one of the things about getting older.
I think just where I
land on this conversation
is I haven't really thought
about the gravestone
until I saw them out there.
I don't necessarily
think I'll get a picture
because where I'm gonna be buried
is probably not Hollywood
Forever Cemetery.
I don't know where I'm gonna get buried.
Well I'm gonna be cremated.
I don't know what I'm gonna do
but if I do get a picture.
So you don't.
It's gonna be an etching
and I think you can get
away with an ambiguous age
in the etching.
Just make me look like it
could be the me that died,
but not as old.
Like take out the bags under the eyes
which I think you can get
away with just with an,
sort of a line drawing.
An example would be helpful.
David Letterman's a good example.
He was famous for years
for this one thing he did,
then he went away and then he came back
and he had this huge beard and
he looked older and different
but he looked distinguished
and he was doing
interviews on Netflix.
That's a good example.
And I think that part of his career
is still kind of happening.
He's certainly not dead
but if you told me,
if a couple of months from he passes away,
what version of him is
gonna be on his headstone
because I think both are viable.
I think the.
I mean the height
of his career was like.
I think it come,
to me.
The Last Show height.
There are three different options
for David Letterman.
Might even be late 80s.
There's three options for him.
There's NBC Letterman, CBS
Letterman and current Letterman
and I think the current Letterman
just doesn't stand a chance at being,
at being on the gravestone.
If it.
I think it comes
down to NBC or CBS.
If it were there,
I wouldn't be appalled you know?
He was still working, he was still active,
he was still a public figure.
So it's not like I would
be like, "That's strange."
And he may.
I do know
that he looked that way.
And he may continue to,
I mean first of all has he
still got the huge beard?
I believe so.
10 years from now
he might not have the huge beard.
Is he gonna really roll with
that for the rest of his life?
But his legacy is his main show.
So I think from a legacy standpoint,
if you can make a tie to that,
then that's what you gotta put up there.
I think it's early CBS.
So it's not just completely
unkempt curly hair,
it's sort of a tight curl
but it's not late era CBS
where he basically had a buzz cut.
Yeah.
He needs the curls
to be Letterman in my mind.
Yeah, yep.
There we go.
We figured it out for him.
Still a little bit
of weatherman in him.
You think we could figure
it out for ourselves.
We could.
I think,
okay if I had to pick
yours, why don't you pick.
You know what?
Let's do that, let's do
that right after the break.
We're gonna pick what we
think is the physical peak.
Not the physical peak,
what would the physical
representation of the other guy?
Okay.
'Cause we may have to make
these decisions for each other.
But first we wanna remind you
about the last chance section
at mythical.com.
We're always releasing stuff
and then we replace it with other stuff
and we don't just
accumulate all the things.
We move on.
Yeah.
That's why it's fun to see
when something new comes out
and decide if you want it
and then if you're on the fence it's like,
you know it ain't gonna be there forever.
Last chance section
is your place to know.
Last chance section.
That it's going away, so.
And once it's gone,
it's gone forever.
Hence your last chance to get it.
That's why we call it that.
And part of the times those,
the last chance section is
offered at a little bit.
Certain products are offered
at a little bit of a discount.
So go over there, mythical.com.
Mythical.com, rep your boys.
Okay I'm going to pick what
I think you should have
on your gravestone and
I am not picking Velma.
The Velma haircut.
I definitely think that
your current haircut
is an improvement.
But I think I would go with,
back when you were dying your hair.
So this is a color?
I mean, I'm just saying.
I like the gray, I think
You made the right decision.
I think letting it go is the right thing
but I think that there's just this.
Letting it go.
There was this little
window of time
in which you had the shape of the hair
that was better than the previous
version but it was still,
you looked so youthful.
So youthful because you
were dying it black.
It was so unrealistically dark.
It bothers me.
Yeah but I think
that won't show up as much.
In an etching.
On an etching.
Okay.
You know?
And it's also easier, to
capture the gray in an etching,
I don't even know how they'll do that.
So I'm really just
thinking about the artist
or the carver.
I mean deciding about,
if your etching has long hair or not,
really is an indication
of what I believe about.
The future?
Our professional future.
Are we going to accomplish
enough that the most,
it will be associated with our legacy?
To apply that Letterman thing to us.
I hope that's the case.
You've gotta do something
man with that hairstyle.
Yeah.
To earn the right
to look like that on your gravestone.
Because right now I'm telling you,
you gotta go back to the,
you gotta go back to the shorter hair
for your gravestone.
Oh man really?
Yeah, you just.
I know I'm really pushing
the achiever button now
and I'm manipulating you.
Well.
I definitely plan on
being along for the ride.
Well the interesting
thing is that that was a,
what you're getting at,
not related to my hair
but related to achievement
is something I wanted to talk about.
Well let's talk about it.
You know I was actually.
In middle age.
This is,
I mean that's what's getting
you thinking about this?
The middle age of it all.
Yeah.
My wife sent me, my wife
will send me a tweet.
My wife is a Twitter fien you know?
And she's always on Twitter.
I think there's a D on
the end of that word.
Fiend.
A fiend is, I thought a fiend is like,
I thought a fiend was an enemy
but a fien is someone who's
really into something?
Like addicted to something.
You lose the D?
I honestly don't know.
I don't know.
I wanna learn though.
All right, we'll find out.
But she's, what is she saying to you?
Well what she'll do is
she will send me a tweet.
You're so old that?
No she sent me a Twitter
thread from a writer
who was talking about the
creator of The Sopranos.
Okay.
I don't remember his name.
And anyway he was like,
I once went to a seminar
or something with this guy
and basically he was super bitter
about the fact that he
had never made it in film.
He got basically forced
to make The Sopranos
into a television show.
It's a long story but
that was the only outlet.
It may have been a contractual
thing with something that.
It's not what he wanted.
It was his face
to do.
Even though it became.
It redefined television.
A television institution.
No, and it didn't just become
a television institution
but the way that we think
about television now
and the golden age of
television that we're in
and the fact that many
actors would prefer to be
in a successful series
rather than a feature.
Yeah.
Is based on,
the first person who really did that,
the first show that did
that was The Sopranos.
The cinematic experience of
bringing you into a story
in a super meaningful and engrossing way
that felt like a movie.
This dude basically made that
happen but yet he was bitter
about having never made it in features.
Now incidentally he did
write and direct I believe
that latest, there's
like a Raid of the Yoda
gangster movie that is
just coming out now.
That's still in The Sopranos world.
The saints something?
Yeah, yeah.
So he got to do it and
he finally got to do it.
But anyway she sent that to me
and she knew exactly why
she was sending it to me
because I'm constantly,
I guess more so than I even
realize complaining to her
about how hard it is for us to get to do
some of the other things
that I think that we should be doing.
Now, I'll premise this with saying that
I'm old enough and wise
enough at this point to know
that regardless of
whatever level of success
on any particular project
lies in the future,
it will make me no happier.
It's not about, it's
not believing that oh,
I will finally be satisfied,
I will finally be happy.
I know that my base of level of happiness
because this is just science,
will always return to
basically what it is.
And I know that the process
of making something,
writing something is probably,
maybe the best part of the whole thing.
Even if it never gets made right?
These things, I know those facts.
It does not stop me from feeling this,
having this insatiable hunger
to achieve something else.
But the thing that I've
been thinking about lately
as it relates to my age is like you know,
at this point, regardless
of what we accomplish next,
it is very unlikely that whatever we do,
even if it's some big,
even if it's like a.
A movie is a movie
and movies don't mean as
much as they used to, right?
I understand that.
But let's just say it was a movie
that everybody was talking
about for a couple of weeks
which is like the best
that you can hope for,
or as a television show that
everybody's talking about
for a few years because it
gets a few seasons or whatever.
These are best case scenarios.
The cultural impact of those projects
will probably never be able to surpass
the cultural impact of
Good Mythical Morning
simply because.
Yeah.
We've done it for so long.
It's 10 years, it's 2000 plus episodes.
It's millions and millions, billions,
billions of views on this thing right?
That at the end of the day.
And that represents
lives touched.
Yeah and here's the thing.
I am super proud of what
that show has accomplished
and what we've been able
to do through the show
and I am passionate about the
fact that it impacts people
but at the same time it,
for reasons we've talked
about before on the show,
it's me and you just kind of
hanging out and having fun.
It's not us creating something
and so the artist in me
and the creator in me still
wants to have that thing
that I can point people to.
Yeah.
And so.
I mean,
and we've created an environment here
with the Mythical team
where it's just as much
a creative expression of our team
in their specific roles as it is of us
expressing our friendship
and our points of view
whenever we do whatever
they've set up for us.
And it doesn't feel the same.
But it's not a creative
challenge day to day
like it was early on.
And it's not a
creative collaboration
between the two of us
in the way that some of the stuff
that we're working on now is.
Yeah.
Like if for instance
the movie that we are writing
and hoping to one day make,
it's so representative of us
and what we want to do.
You talking about,
you're talking about the S&M movie?
Well that is one way to describe it.
I just.
But it's misleading
because it's not about sadomasochism.
Yeah but that's what,
that's what we're gonna
call it because I want,
when it is successful
and when it is the reason
your gravestone face changes Rhett,
I want people to know
that's what specifically
we were talking about.
Our S&M movie.
Yeah I do it.
All right so now we have a code name
for it.
The S&M movie.
Which by the way, just to give a timeline,
we birthed that concept
less than a year ago.
It might have been about?
Early, early 2021.
Yeah.
Early 2021.
No, no no.
2020.
Late 2020 because I remember
this pie in the sky.
It's almost a year ago now.
I had this pie in the sky idea
that it would be written
over Christmas break.
Aha, that's right.
It's since
and literally the writing
process starts today.
Yeah which is why it's so much
on the forefront of our minds.
'Cause it's been lots of
outlining and all that.
But when you think about, at this age,
you really start to think about legacy
and there's other ways that
you think about it besides this
but we might as well get, fully explore
just the creative professional
aspect of our legacy
'cause that is what we,
that is what you start to
think about at this age.
Well to me it's, yeah that's part of it
but I think the, where
the age gets in there
is a fear that
my best work is behind me.
So it's kind of a two
part thing that like okay,
can you, are you even capable of this?
You know, yeah okay sure you,
this movie is, there's
going to be a script
and that may be all that it ever is.
We may get lucky enough for it to be made,
for somebody to give us money to make it
and then it's like,
"Well will people care about it?"
And like I said, I know
that the happiness is not.
Even if people love it, it's
not gonna make me any happier.
It might make me happy for a day
but I'll immediately begin
thinking about the next thing.
That's just human nature.
So it's not about that but it's about
kind of proving to myself that I can,
that I can do this.
There's this creative challenge
that I can't say no to,
moving through it and being
like hey, there it is.
I did that, what's the next thing?
That's just kind of how I live my life.
But as I'm now 44,
there's this man, like,
in reality we kind of got started
at this whole creative
game kind of late right?
You know when most YouTubers
were getting started at 20,
we were getting started at 30.
So we got a little bit of,
we got a 10-year, we were delayed 10 years
just because of the nature of life.
We got into the YouTube game very early
and we've been doing it
for a very long time.
But boy, there's just
part me of that's like,
"Oh man, I wish I could
press a button and be 34
"because then I would
have this confidence."
How many, how many artists
have really created
amazing things in their
40s and beyond right?
These are the things
that I start thinking.
I'm being vulnerable and
honest about my fears.
It's just like,
"Man if you haven't done it
yet, you probably can't do it.
"You're probably not capable of it."
And so then it's like, and listen.
These are very privileged problems.
I understand that many people
in the entertainment business
would give a limb to have
the success that we have had
with Good Mythical Morning alone.
I get that, that's not,
that's not what I'm saying.
I'm not saying I'm not grateful
for the success we have had.
Yeah.
But there is this just like,
man is that really, is that gonna be it?
Is that gonna be the thing
that everyone remembers us for
and is that gonna be the
last thing that we got to do
that was special to anyone
just besides the two of us?
Yeah and I think the way
that I interact with this,
because I also think about it is,
I find that my instinctive
thoughts go more towards
still this scarcity mentality
and it kind of being tied to well,
is the money gonna run
out before my life does?
You know it's like, I just
think things like that.
It's like, we have a,
we have a lifestyle that we enjoy.
It's like, okay I wanna.
I don't wanna have to go back to being,
doing things out of obligation.
We've been very spoiled and privileged
with going after our dreams
and being successful.
It, you know, on top of it.
So I think we balance each
other out well that like,
you know, I'm.
I tend to be grateful for what we have,
and like oh I wanna
maintain this at all cost
and you're grateful for what we have
but you wanna build on
it as much as you can.
And so I, you know I try
to understand my tendency
and then put it in its place and say,
"Hey, I still do have ambition.
"I'm not just somebody
"who just wants to maintain a lifestyle."
I don't wanna be that person.
But I think we have different,
different instinctive drives
at the heart of us.
With me it's more of like, maintain.
Yeah and my desire to work on other things
is not really tied to any,
it's definitely not tied to
finances because I already know
that the most lucrative
thing that I'll ever do
is Good Mythical Morning.
I mean very likely,
statistically speaking.
Yeah.
Right?
Because it's just so much content
and it's just, it works
really well for us.
If we, we would have to have
just like this total moonshot
of a moment in, in TV or film or whatever.
And again.
To begin to approach
the success.
I also, I wanna.
Because a lot of people,
whenever we talk like this,
a lot of people are like,
"Guys, why do you, you have this obsession
"with traditional media and
it's only because of your age.
"And because you guys
grew up with TV and film."
Yeah, which to The Sopranos point.
Yeah and.
It's like why would you?
You blazed the trail for
every other scripted show
and you still set the standard.
People are rediscovering
your work every day
and appreciating it.
Somehow because of TikTok.
Well.
They're watching Sopranos.
And I think,
and I think that my particular hangup
is more, I'm saying this.
I think my particular
hangup is more justified
than The Sopranos guy's
hangup and here's why.
Because he got to create a world.
The difference between
The Sopranos and a film,
again it's just.
Right.
It's format.
The difference between,
when I say TV and film.
I don't mean, I don't care
about traditional media.
If you told me tomorrow that me and you
could make a movie with an adequate budget
in order to pull it off in
the way that we wanted to
and it would just go straight to YouTube,
I'd, that's fine.
I'm not trying to win an Oscar.
I'm not trying to get
respect from any particular
part of the entertainment industry.
I just want to be able to
tell the kinds of stories
that we wanna tell.
And right now there's
just not a financial model
to do that in the sort of completely owned
and controlled independent
vehicle that we have right now
with digital media.
So it kind of goes
through the powers that be
and the finances and all that stuff.
So it has nothing to do with an obsession
with TV and film and traditional.
It's more an obsession
with storytelling, now.
Until, until you check that box
and then you see what it becomes next.
For you, because it is a moving target.
Well but it's something,
but it's the first thing.
It's the first, I don't agree with that.
Okay.
Because yeah,
my interests are a moving target
but we got into this business
because we wanted to tell stories.
We wrote Gutless Wonders at 14
We did a blood oath because
we wanted to tell stories.
Like when we said we wanted
to create something together,
we didn't know what it was specifically
but both of us were talking about,
we were talking about
going to film school.
Sure.
We were talking about
creating a world, telling stories
and we have been able to do
that in some fashion right?
And we got to write a
novel that was a world
that came to life and maybe
that will become something.
It isn't that we're not
trying, we're still trying.
But yeah, to me it's
the difference between
what we do on Good
Mythical Morning which is,
it has an incredible value
and is incredibly rewarding.
It's just, the creative
process for me personally
is a totally different thing
than something that we have
conceptualized, written and executed
and birthed in that way.
I get that.
And I think if we, if we shift to,
from a personal and
philosophical standpoint
what it means to be, to
process being middle aged,
I think we could
superimpose that discussion
over top of what we've already discussed
because the next thing
that comes to my mind
that I'm grateful for about my age
is just starting to realize perspective.
Starting to realize
that I actually do have
some accumulated wisdom.
And for me, the first place my brain goes
that I'm grateful for is,
I feel like I'm well
positioned to know myself.
Like I was telling Christy,
at a younger age, I feel like
I might have had the desire
and some of the drive to know myself,
understand what makes me
tick and what ticks me off
and every other type of tick.
But there's something
about this age that I can,
I can start to really experience
a level of self knowledge
that I just don't think was
possible when we were in college
or when we were grinding
and trying to make it early on you know?
So I'm actually enjoying that.
That, again we have the luxury of having
some space and time to
give attention to ourselves
in a way that's like, I'm still evolving.
I'm still changing and
I'm very committed to
being in touch with that process
and understanding myself.
And I think that that is,
a portion of that with us is aging.
I think also a big portion of it is
the worldview change that we had right?
So I think.
Yeah it's like,
we were being redefined in
our late 30s.
But specifically,
what I'm getting at is,
when you are an evangelical Christian
or when I was an evangelical Christian,
there is a, thinking a little bit too,
too much focus on self.
It's all about attention to God right
and you are small and God is big
and there are some very good
things about a mentality
of not centering yourself
and humbling yourself
and I believe that there's
some good qualities there.
But one of the things that
kind of gets wrapped up in that
is that any sort of self discovery
and looking in to yourself
and knowing that there's
something in there
that needs to be
expressed and to come out.
Could begin, you start
confusing that with sinful pride
and so the way my personality processed
a lot of that structure
was this feeling that like,
I'm not important enough to
really figure myself out.
Now I not saying that's everybody
but I think it stunted my growth
of self realization and self discovery.
When I got out of that way
of thinking about things
and started thinking like,
I gotta really figure myself out.
It's not just about understanding God
and the Bible and then my,
my relationship to that,
but it's also like this is
the body and mind that I have.
I need to figure out who I am
and there's nothing wrong
with that and that sort of,
you can call it selfishness
but directing some actual
attention to yourself,
learning how to love yourself
so that you can actually be a
better citizen and a better,
love people better and be less
selfish and self absorbed.
For me, I think that was
the beginning of a process
that eventually led to
therapy and led to the sort of
self discovery and figuring out who I am
and as a Enneagram 3,
another thing that happens
is that you're really good
at figuring out who everyone
else wants you to be.
You can analyze a person
or a group of people,
figure out the ideal and then
you just adopt that ideal.
And it wasn't until the
past five years or so
that I began to figure out
that so many of the things that I liked
or a lot of the ways
that I presented myself
were just based on people's perception
and so for me, getting older, a part of it
has been A, discovering myself.
But B, also being able to
embrace some things about myself
irrespective of people's
perspective of me.
Is there an example that comes to mind
of something that you
realize you were doing
because of that?
Because I don't know exactly
what you're talking about
as it relates to you.
Well it's more of a disposition
of thinking about like,
oh is that something that I want
or is that something that I think
that someone thinks I should want?
And it could be something as simple as
oh I'm going to like
this movie or whatever,
I'm going to say that I like this movie
because I think that other
people like this movie
and I started realizing that
it was just kind of built into my DNA
to be able to anticipate what
the collective consciousness
about something was gonna
be and tapping into that
and this is still a struggle for me.
To be like what do you
actually think about this?
Right, I mean a good example
is what we talked about
a couple weeks ago with the guitar right?
Oh.
Getting a Taylor guitar
because it was what I thought
that I should like at the time
and environment that I was in.
And then slowly as I got older,
being like I find myself
liking these other sounds
and then I go and I look up well,
what does so and so play?
What does so and so play?
That's not a Taylor, that's a Martin.
Okay.
Or that's a Gibson.
And it's like that's a sound
that you actually liked
but when I went to a music store,
even the last time I bought a guitar,
when I went into the music
store it's like I only,
I sat down and I just
played the Taylors right?
And it's just this weird thing
and it's not because that I think
oh liking Taylor is better.
It's just you made that
decision in the past
for somebody else and now you
kind of just carry it through
into adulthood.
So it's kind of this peeling
back things like that.
Yeah the peeling back experience
to get to the core of myself is something
that I'm now in a position to do.
For me, Evangelicalism,
growing up in that was like,
"Okay, I want to
aggressively learn the system
"so that then I can know enough about it
"and put into practice
the spiritual disciplines
"and then I can go about
the rest of my life
"having fully explored the manual
"and just executing it."
Yeah.
It's not about asking
difficult questions or
wringing my soul out
to really analyze who I am
and the whys of life for me.
Because that felt like a scary burden
apart from someone just
giving me all the answers
in a nice package.
Yeah.
Turns out
the package wasn't completely nice
but I gained a lot of security from that
and I did have this mentality that was,
I'm going to just, the
second half of my life
is just gonna be about applying everything
that I've already learned.
I just didn't anticipate
that there could be so much
more to learn out there
and there was a lot of fear
in crossing over to the other side
because of all the unknowns
that we've discussed
but yeah, actually being
there is a very freeing
and rewarding, and still
at times very scary process
because it's, it's not
well laid out and rigid.
It's much more fluid.
But it's enabled me to know myself
at a totally deeper level
and I think that's the experience
that I want to define my life.
I found myself talking a lot in therapy
about situations that I'm
going through and experiencing
and then discussing making meaning of it.
You know, how as humans we
want to, we wanna make meaning
and that enriches an experience
and kind of codifies it in our memories.
As not, and being present and
making the most of something.
Just wringing everything
out of it that there is
I think is the philosophy
and the approach that I'm taking now.
And it's something that,
I think it's still a struggle for me.
It's something I've identified,
this is how I wanna live my life.
But I also know enough about myself that
I'm prone to be stuck in my ways.
Like you talk about the
second, the second half of life
and just the whole trope
of being set in my ways
is something that is a discussion
that goes on a lot at my house.
Whether it's you know, just
deciding that I want things
to be in a certain way and
routines are so huge for me.
Especially as an Enneagram 1.
It's like once I've figured something out,
I'm gonna make this movie
this way and not only that
but I'm gonna make it at this time
and I'm gonna get my
ingredients in this way
and if anybody messes anything
up, that really irks me.
Or I have these plans to
do something with the kids.
Like yesterday, we're
gonna go one wheeling
and I'm texting you
so I can borrow one for you from Lincoln.
I'm like, "Make sure
thing thing's charged up."
And then I go out to get them, mine,
and put them in the
trunk before I go pick up
your fully charged one when I realize,
Lando's has been in the
back of my car for two weeks
and it barely has any
charge and I was so upset.
And that's one of the first things
when I was bouncing this
discussion off of Christy,
she was like, you know,
"Getting older, you have a tendency
"to be set in your ways and
anything that throws that off,
"just it really, it really throws you off.
"And if you don't."
And I agree with this,
so it wasn't like a warning out the blue.
Right.
= But it was like,
"Hey if you don't look out for this,
"you're gonna become
somebody who builds this,
"these walls around yourself and says,
"'I'm just trying to maintain what I have
"'and the way that I want it.'"
And then it lets fewer and
fewer new experiences in.
So I think that's the, that's the tension
that I'm experiencing at
this point in midlife is
knowing enough of who I am
to celebrate and love myself
but not allow that to keep me from
who I'm still going to become.
Yeah.
So even having
the words to say that
is a part of the journey that I've been on
just in the last few years
and that I really enjoy in saying,
you know, the openness
from leaving Evangelicalism
and saying, "I wanna be open
minded and open hearted."
And then applying that to things beyond
just your spiritual beliefs
but to every aspect of your life
is something that I'm still growing into.
Well one of the things
that maybe an unspoken,
it's actually not unspoken.
Because Evangelical Christians
and Christians in general
see God, one of the
characteristics of God,
the attributes of God is
His immutability right?
Which means.
Doesn't change.
He does not change.
That's one of the things
that makes God God.
He is always the same.
So that becomes something
that you kind of aspire to.
Implicitly.
And I think there's also an obsession
in our culture.
'Cause when you're right,
why change?
There's also an obsession in our culture
with staying the same right?
We get so mad when a politician
flip flops on something.
And it's like, that's
the stupidest perspective
I've ever heard in my life
because you know what?
New information causes
people to change their mind.
Now it's one thing if somebody flip flops,
and many politicians flip
flop because of convenience
and wanting to be more electable.
That's one thing.
Right.
But when somebody's like,
"I used to think this about this issue,
"now I think this because
my view has evolved."
That's something that should be,
that process should be celebrated.
That's not some reason
not to like somebody.
But I think one of the things that
because we have experienced
this incredible evolution
and this upheaval of our worldview,
it's given us this, just
sort of underlying belief
that it's not about being this certain way
and figuring that out and
just staying that way.
It's just like, there's a version
of Rhett 10 years from now
and then a version of
Rhett 20 years from now
and I hope that those versions are better
but I know that those versions
are going to be different
and they may be different in
ways that I can't anticipate
and that's a super exciting thing.
Now there are some things that may be
more of a refining process of
kind of figuring yourself out.
You know, when you talk about the,
the sort of savoring
and being in the moment.
One of the things that I've
kind of embraced about myself
is that I have a really
difficult time doing that right?
We even wrote on our whole chapter
in the Book of Mythicality
about stopping and celebrating
and I'm not saying that I don't
agree with that in general.
If you achieve something,
you know, stop and enjoy it.
And really appreciate this moment.
But there's also just a,
there's the way that I am
and the way that I sort
of operate in the world
is that the moment that
I achieve one goal,
I'm ready for the next
thing and I think that,
I'm starting to understand
that that's not a bad thing for me.
You know what I'm saying?
That whole process,
like every single stage
along the different steps of a project
and then it finally coming to fruition,
when I get kind of focused
on that moment of achieving
and that moment of
completing and being like,
"Hold on everybody, let's
stop and really celebrate
"and let's go to dinner
and let's really milk this
"for all it's worth."
For me it's kind of like,
I wanna milk each step for all it's worth
and make sure that I'm
not just looking at that,
accomplishing the goal
as being the end all
because really, it may be, like I said,
the writing, the
conceptualizing that ends up,
when I look back on this,
the most fun part of this whole process
wasn't when we finally
screened that movie,
it was when we came up with the idea
or when we had that breakthrough
in the storytelling process.
Then the thing is is that,
it's not gonna make me any happier anyway
so why don't you just
move on to the next thing?
Like I'm learning to not
get upset with myself for,
I don't wanna say not being present
because I wanna be present.
I wanna be present at each step
but not stopping and saying that like,
"I'm going to make a huge
fricking deal out of this thing."
It's like what, does
that come natural to me?
Not really, I mean I'm gonna enjoy it
and let's celebrate but hey,
I know that the next day I'm gonna wake up
and I'm gonna be like, "What's next?"
And that's okay.
And that may be something
that's good about me right?
Versus being like,
"Oh you can never be
satisfied and that's bad."
Maybe that sort of insatiable
hunger for the next thing
is just part of my
disposition and my personality
and something I should embrace.
The moment that I began thinking
that I can find my happiness
in the things that I achieve,
I've gone off track.
But if I can find happiness in the process
and knowing that hey man,
oh there's one of the things
I've been talking about
with my therapist is that as I talk about
the different facets of
what we do professionally
and of course being essentially CEOs
of a media company takes
up a fair amount of time.
And of course that's not my
favorite part of what we do.
My favorite of what we
do is the creative part
and the way he kind of,
the way my therapist kind of described it,
he was like, "You kind of get into,
"the way you talk about it
"is as if you're in sort of a zone
"when you're in this creative zone
"and as you get older
you're learning to make sure
"that you're getting that time
"and you're getting that creative space
"because that's where you find life."
And he's helped me be able to see that
that's not an unhealthy thing
because when I start describing it to him,
I start describing it in this like,
I feel a little bit guilty
for how bad I wanna do X, Y and Z.
That's my threeness.
That's my achiever and that's my performer
and that's bad because I'm
trying to find my identity
in the things that I'm creating.
And he's like,
"Whoa whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
"No, no no.
"There is an incredible
goodness and health and life
"in your being in a creative zone
"and finding life in
the creative process."
That's a good thing.
Now the moment that you start trying
to do it for other people
and you're starting to do it for adulation
and people to kind of pat you on the back,
that's trouble but
understanding that you need that
and you want that and you're never gonna,
you're never gonna be satisfied
unless you're creating
and that might be the next
thing, that's a good thing.
So that's something that I've.
So I've sort of let go of
my guilt of being like,
what we talked about earlier.
Like the fact that yeah we're
doing all this other stuff
but I still have 10 other
things that I want us to do.
That's not a bad thing
and I can embrace that
and that's not unhealthy.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah definitely and I think that it's,
again it's back to understanding
enough about myself,
you understanding enough
about yourself to,
to begin to parse what
your motivations are
but not a beat yourself up
and not to over-interpret things.
It's like every single thing
that you pour yourself into,
there's, it could lead to a problem
or it could lead to
something worth celebrating.
It's great right?
But if you're, yeah I'm glad to hear
that you're not beating yourself up
and just reducing your
desire to something that
is motivated by the wrong
things but gaining clarity.
I think as, again at our age,
we can have enough
perspective to gain clarity
on what a vibrant life can look
and feel like for each of us.
And understanding the parts of it
that are actually healthy.
That was a big shift for me.
You know, I'm thinking about it
because of this movie that
we're right in the middle of
this creative process.
If you told me, like I should be okay
if for some reason I was
able to look in the future
and find that this movie
was never going to be made
into anything other than a script.
Now that would be disheartening for sure.
I like to believe that
it's going to happen
but the process of writing
it should be enjoyable
and vibrant and life-giving
regardless of the outcome.
If it doesn't get made into a movie,
it doesn't mean that the
process of writing it
and developing it was for nothing
because there was joy
and life in the process.
Yeah.
And that's a huge shift
for me as an achiever.
I can't get rid of the engine
that is always putting me,
is always in a certain gear and as soon,
the moment you turn it off and say,
"Hey let's the engine rest."
I'm like, ah let's turn
the engine back on.
I can't stop that about myself
and that's not necessarily unhealthy.
It's the perspective if all of a sudden
that engine is running for
everybody else's expectations.
And so that's been a huge shift
that's kind of happened in
the therapy process with me.
Of kind of just eh, this is who you are.
This is how you're built, embrace it
and know the pitfalls.
Yeah I mean there's so
many ways that we're alike,
so many ways that we're different.
When you talk about letting go
of other people's
expectations for me, I'm like,
yeah I think my practice
is letting go of my own expectations.
That I've created.
Yeah.
And this you know, to have this sense of
and practice of control.
Like this morning I've got my
mountain bike ride that I do
and it's the same.
So I can measure myself against
it in order to get better,
to be a little faster and more efficient.
Which shows progress.
But I heard an owl hooting
and I made a decision.
You know what, I'm gonna find this out
and this morning, you know
you've been talking about owls
for a couple of months now
and how you've seen them.
It's kind of really upset.
I've seen owls.
I've not seen an owl.
Everywhere.
And then I looked up and I saw an owl.
It was very dark, the
sun hadn't come up yet.
So it was like the silhouette of an owl
on this big power tower.
You know the power towers?
The power towers.
Yeah so I saw an owl.
It's a beautiful thing.
And I stopped my route.
I paused my podcast.
Did you call to him?
And I listened and looked at the owl
and then I rode around to the other side
and I wanted to see
the backside of the owl
but then his head can
turn around all the way.
Yeah.
Give or take.
Which is an owl thing
which was cool to experience.
Did he do that?
I think he did that.
He looked at you?
His head turned
all the way around.
He was following you?
Yeah, I mean it was a silhouette but I,
that's what I was imagining happened.
You choose to believe that he was pivoting
to look at you.
Yeah, let's talk about things
we hate about getting old.
Well.
For me this can be quick.
I think what you got at
with the mountain biking
ties in to something that I was thinking
which is a little bit of good
and a little bit of bad of getting old.
So there is this refining process
from a physical standpoint right?
So you're talking about
the mountain biking
and improving your
times but the problem is
is that your body is only
heading in the wrong direction.
So you can.
Yeah.
You can get, and I've
been thinking about this
because you know I'm
pretty physically active
and I work out on a pretty regular basis
and a lot of it is based on
sort of thinking about my,
the things I wanna be
able to do and longevity,
especially as it relates to my back right?
So my back has been a problem on and off,
even when I was looking at
those anniversary videos
or the honeymoon videos.
That we ended up putting into the podcast
with Jessie and Christy on it.
I listened to some of
them with the sound on
and one of the things
I was complaining about
in that video when I was 23
was how bad my back was hurting.
So this is a long, this is a multi.
Huh.
You know over
a couple of decades of
struggling with this
and so so much of my working out
is designed to make my back better
and a few months ago I
was getting to a place
where I was doing squats and
dead lifts and I was like,
"I think I have overcome my back issues."
I always get to this plate.
And then I pushed it a little too hard
and I had my.
It broke.
You broke your back.
I had a moment.
And that actually set me on a course of,
it was a couple of months
of dealing with the pain
and not being able to work out
in the way that I wanted to.
But I ended up kind of embracing
when I came out of that time I was like,
"You can't, you don't need to be,
"you don't need to be
doing dead lifts okay?"
Let's just take dead lifts
out of the workout routine.
It just doesn't make any sense right?
I mean it's got the word dead in it.
But this was, there's this idea that
there's a sort of physical refinement.
Like I'm learning the
things that hurt my back.
I'm learning the things that hurt my,
I've got a shoulder thing right?
I got a shoulder thing.
And I'm learning, I had to change me,
even though I don't play golf that often,
I had like a net that I
hit balls into at my house
just on a pretty regular basis.
I'll go out there and hit
10 balls or something.
I've had to change my swing
based on a new pain in my back
but also my shoulder.
And so there's this,
this idea that you're
refining and you're learning
some things about your body
but at the same time, every
single process in your body
is heading in the wrong direction.
And every single thing
that you're dealing with
is only going to.
All the factors are stacked against you.
You can resist it and you
can do a really good job
of trying to stay in shape, et cetera
but everything is just heading
in the wrong direction.
That's a, that's a.
Right.
There's a sense of impending doom
when you really think about that.
Well yeah, I think in the
way that we discuss parenting
as being okay,
you shift to this paradigm
of harm reduction.
Definitely understanding
my body is another way.
I've gotten in touch more with my body.
Knowing what the limits are
and from my physical therapist,
gaining an education on,
like okay, when you reach too far,
you hyper-extend yourself and
then that's a danger zone.
So actually knowing the safe limits
with which I can reach and.
Reach for what, anything?
Anything.
A jar?
Yeah.
You know, like I'm sure with your back
and when I worked at IBM in the warehouse,
they would have all these things
about how to properly lift something.
Yeah, yeah.
Lift with your legs,
not your back, two man lift.
Don't twist, don't lift and twist.
All these things that you know,
at our age you really start to understand.
Okay the way that my shoulders are built
and my collarbones and my rotator cuffs,
I can really, I have to be aware
because my body will go,
if I push it to the limit, physically,
that will cause damage.
I have to be aware of
that, educate myself.
And yeah know that I'm
just trying to do things
to be active and to strengthen
myself but reduce harm.
You know?
Not hurt myself.
Every time I go to the gym it's like,
this could be the day that I hurt myself
and I'm not gonna be able
to go back to the gym.
Yeah.
Like mountain biking.
I see guys who are 10,
15 years older than me
out there doing exactly what I'm doing.
That gives me hope.
It's like okay there's,
there's a version of mountain biking
that I can continue into
older age 'cause I'm probably,
I'm not gonna get into golf you know?
Like you are.
There's a version of golf that you can do
as long as you don't have like,
as long as you continue
to know your limits right?
Yeah, and it's tough.
There are some things
like, I definitely relate
to the, like the way that I hold myself.
I mean I'm sure you can just look
at some of the more
physical videos that we do.
I'm a little stiff.
I'm actually, if you go back to old Rhett,
like young Rhett.
I'm was, I'm not.
You were floppy?
I'm not stiff.
I was super flexible and
I'm actually still flexible
but I don't move the center of my body.
Yeah.
In really,
I'm careful with how I move
because I'm so concerned
with getting hurt.
And then, I remember,
if I'm hiking and I'm going
really quickly down a mountain,
I remember the way that I
used to do that as kids,
sometimes we would just start running.
Remember the time we ran
down Grandfather Mountain?
Yeah.
And it's like now,
I'm going 30% speed if I'm running.
But like, my whole core is really tight
because I'm, the core has gotta be tight.
There's just a whole lot of
extra thought that's going on.
There's technique.
But then there's things like oh,
I know that this food will
cause my psoriasis to flare up.
Or I know if I have,
if I drink alcohol two days in a row,
oh you're gonna get a flareup.
If you eat this food, you
really should take a beano
before you eat this food.
Or you know what?
If you have this particular meal,
you should just go ahead
and take a dose of Pepto-Bismol
right after you get through with it.
Oh.
There's these old man ways
of thinking about things
that are a little bit disheartening.
Yeah.
But it's also,
you figured some stuff out.
You're not just, you can't
because you're not young anymore.
You can't just go into a situation
with reckless abandon and be like,
"I'll deal with the consequences."
But you're also learning some things
about yourself physically so
that you can prepare for them.
So there's good, and
there's two sides of that.
There's some good in it and then,
but the ultimate reality is,
it's all heading in the wrong direction.
When you talk about the 10, the 15 years.
Right.
You talk,
you got 10 to 15 years
left of mountain biking
and then you're gonna hang it up.
You can't think of it like that obviously.
Yeah.
But that,
it's sort of the overhanging reality
is that it's all gonna get
harder and more difficult
and more consequential as we get older
and you just have to accept it.
I'll tell you the other thing I hate
is hair popping up in places.
Like I realize,
I've got all this hair
growing on my ears now.
Oh yeah.
I'm not.
I covered it up with other hair.
I mean not inside of the ear,
like the outside edge.
Right here.
Yeah.
I've got hairs growing and
that there's black ones.
You've gotta have somebody
in your life who sees that.
I shaved this morning.
And helps you with it.
And every time that I shave.
I have a magnifying mirror.
First of all, here's
something that I learnt.
I don't,
a commitment to actually
look at myself in the mirror.
Like okay, this is you,
I'm gonna look at it
and I'm going to assess
it and I'm gonna do,
I'm gonna make decisions
to do stuff about it
and I'm gonna make decisions
about what I'm not gonna do stuff about
and I'm just gonna, I'm
gonna accept who I am
and figure out what
I'm gonna work on here.
Christy's given me all
these night lotions.
It's like, what's happening?
I have glasses, I don't
know if you knew that.
But if I take those off,
the thing that the glasses covers up
is the places where there's
like, that's where age happens.
Yeah.
So glass.
I've been aging.
Get you
nice thick glasses.
Out in the open
for many years.
Yeah and I've been hiding
behind these glasses.
The Red Hot Chili Peppers,
I don't know how old they are now.
I think they might be pushing,
they're in their mid 50s at least.
Yeah.
They announced
their new tour and it
was trending on YouTube
and I was like, "Damn."
I mean they look old but
not as old as they are.
Yeah.
But I was like,
we're still gonna be announcing tours
and doing stuff one day
and people are gonna be racking up.
We're gonna have to say things like,
Jon Stewart with his new show.
I don't know if you've seen the promotions
for his new show but he's like,
"Yeah this is what I look like now."
Yeah, yeah he just did.
He's totally gray
and wrinkle faced and just aged.
Yeah.
'Cause he went away
for a little bit and he
came back and he's like,
this is what everybody.
Yeah this is what I
look like now.
Well I've noticed this
now that we're on TikTok
and there's people who were
you know.
Yeah.
10 years old or whatever
the last time they watched us and wow,
"Wow you guys got old."
We did.
Now it was,
at the same time I'm grateful for the fact
that I do think we're
aging rather gracefully.
There's things that we do.
Most people are surprised to
hear we're as old as we are.
We've got full heads of hair.
There's lots to be grateful for
in the physical department.
Yeah.
And I'm grateful for the gray hair
'cause I'm just grateful for the hair.
Right but at the same time,
it, there are days in,
again like you said.
I don't wear glasses and also my,
my eyes are different.
I have different kinds of eyes
that are a little bit
buggier and I have sort of,
I don't know what the
genetic name for this is
but I have the sort of eye bags.
I've had them forever.
But they're the kinds
of things that I can,
I look at old men, certain
old men and I'm like,
"He's got my kind of eyes
"and that's where I'm headed."
Oh God.
And the aging apps,
like some fans have sent us through those
and the Donald Sutherland version of you.
Yeah that's.
Is so,
we both look so real 'cause
I look like my granddad
and when he was elderly.
Yeah.
And like, how my dad's getting now.
It's like oh my God,
that is scarily accurate.
I know exactly, yeah that's
the beauty of it.
But for some reason
I'm still wearing the exact same glasses
which I think may be the case.
I think when I'm 80, I might
still be wearing these glasses
because I've been trying to change them up
and I keep going back to them.
But I mean I got hair,
I shaved the hair on my ears.
Just to keep it down and I'll
use the nose hair trimmers
inside of my ears.
In ear, yeah.
And boy I've looked
inside of your ear to know
that you got a lot of that stuff happening
inside of your ear.
Yeah.
But I don't think
you have the outer rim,
black hair growth that I do.
But I mean.
Now yeah.
I gotta get down in that magnifying glass
and look at it.
So back to what I was saying
about looking at yourself in the mirror.
The thing that I noticed
was that I just don't
look at myself enough.
I think there's a lot of people
who look at themselves too much
and they obsess about things
and it's not healthy.
But the thing that I would notice
is when I'm getting ready in the morning
and fixing my hair,
I will, over the course of fixing my hair,
I will step back and step
back and I will realize
that I have gotten four or
five paces from the mirror
while I'm fixing my hair.
The longer I fix my hair,
the further from the
mirror I get and I do,
I just some.
I think it's a subconscious practice of,
I'll probably be happier with it
if I don't scrutinize it as much.
And then I, when I'm done I'm like,
I have to take five steps
back up to the mirror
and certify, am I good?
'Cause I actually, it's
kind of a good practice.
Maybe you're getting
different angles or something.
To be far from somebody
it's like all right,
I spotted Link, I recognized him
and I had a conclusion
about what he looked like.
I got this, because
I've done the five paces
but then I've gone back up and it's like,
now I'm gonna go up and talk to him.
And now I'm gonna see is that,
is there a zit on his face?
If you get really close,
is there hair on his ears?
If he gets intimate,
like there's sometimes when
I really go through a process
and I'm gonna use that magnifying mirror,
imma get rid of all this stuff.
I have hairs growing on my nose.
Yeah.
Like black hairs.
Yeah yeah.
Growing on the bridge
of my nose.
I get those sometimes.
I don't shave those.
You pluck those.
I pluck those individually
and I've gotten pretty good at it.
Sometimes I'll just touch
the bridge of my nose
and I can feel if there's a
hair that needs to be plucked.
Do you use a serum, a face serum?
Like an, it's like an oil with a dropper?
Yeah that's got like the
blood of virgins in it.
Not yet, I'm sure I will
once you finish talking about it.
Oh I use it.
I mean.
At night,
it's a night serum?
Well it's.
It makes it nice and shiny.
Well it's actually,
they suggest that you
use it in the morning.
What I've found is my
eyes are so sensitive
and already very red all the time
if I don't put my drops in.
I really can't put anything
on my face in the morning.
I just wash it and I put a little,
little moisturizer here
of some spots like some,
I have eczema or psoriasis or something
that would kind of pop up on my face.
But I, so I started doing it at night.
I've actually been doing,
I don't know if you knew
this but I've been doing the,
I've been putting moisturizer,
anti-aging moisturizer
on my face for like,
I don't know like seven or eight years.
Well how I would know that?
You're keeping this a secret.
You're trying to underage me.
I mean.
You've gotta
give me these serums.
Christy's been giving me these serums,
maybe you haven't realized.
But I've done doing.
I've got some night creams.
Yeah but now I'm pretty much down to man,
this one, I got this one.
This stuff, it's a little bottle.
It'll last you a couple of months.
It's $150.
Good God.
But it's the only thing
that I'm currently using
'cause I was using like a retinol thing
and then a moisturizer over that.
Yeah.
But I'm pretty much
just doing that, 'cause I mean listen.
I'm trying to, I'm trying
to delay the inevitable.
I don't, I know that we're
gonna eventually look our age
but I'm like, why not try to stave it off
as long as possible?
Why not?
Now the real question's gonna be,
when I do get the Donald Sutherland bags,
'cause they're coming and
they're coming with a vengeance,
is there gonna be this moment,
like 15, 20 years from now
when I'm 65 years old,
when all of a sudden
I start thinking whatever
Kenny Rogers thought
before he got his bags removed
and suddenly looked
like a different person.
Yeah, you don't wanna do that.
You don't wanna.
At this point.
You don't want to assume
an alter ego late in life.
Right but what.
When you're cosplaying
as your younger self but
it looks like a mask.
But then you've got some
doctor who says like hey.
I can do it.
I can do this
and no one will know.
Oh you're paying $150 for a serum.
I can do some stuff for you.
I get some.
I'm not ruling.
Oceanfront property
in Arizona.
I'm not ruling any.
I'm just telling you right now,
I'm not ruling anything out.
Hey you shouldn't.
The way technology's changing Donald.
Yeah.
You could,
you'd be just fine.
But yeah it is, talk about eyes.
It's an eyeopening experience to see that,
those aged photos of us
and you start to think,
I wanna be healthy enough to
toss my grandchildren around
and a little bit of those
great grandchildren.
And I wanna be able to see
them through my eye bags.
Yeah.
I don't want them
pulling on them.
"Grandad, let me pull on your eye bags."
I don't hate too much besides my hair.
I've pretty much given up on the fact that
I'm never gonna have a big chest.
I can't get.
Never gonna have
a big chest.
I can't make my chest
have muscle on it.
My pecs won't do anything
and when I try to build it,
all it does is mess up my
shoulders because I'm like.
We need to get you on the Marvel, Marvel.
I'm doing pushups and
now my shoulder hurts
or a bench press, I can't
do any of that stuff.
I can not, that's the other thing
I haven't liked about
my body is I just can't,
I can't get pecs to grow.
You're doing pretty good
in the shoulder department.
That's the thing that I worked
on constantly is you know,
I don't like the shape of everything.
So I can get a chest.
Yeah you can get a chest.
But I can't get,
I don't even work my chest out anymore.
'Cause I'm like, "It's big enough, okay."
It's like, work on the shoulders.
But I think this is it.
I think this is as.
Unless I.
With our powers combined.
I think unless I start, if get on gear
as Locke would say.
That's the.
Headgear?
That's the term for steroids.
Seriously?
Your son wants you to take steroids?
No I'm saying like, he's like,
"Dad all those guys, all those superheroes
"in the Marvel movies,
they're on gear dad.
"That's not natty."
Natural.
Natural, okay.
He's not suggesting I do it.
But he's just like,
"But if you really wanted to get big,
"you'd have to get on gear."
Anything else you hate?
I just wanna be thorough.
So I'm just gonna
let you know, if all of
a sudden I'm really big,
I'm probably on steroids.
What else do you hate?
I just wanna make sure
we don't miss anything.
About getting older?
Yeah.
You know I have thoroughly established
how much I do not like
myself without a beard.
People talked about,
when they saw my honeymoon
videos and my wedding pictures
of like, "See, Rhett doesn't
look bad without a beard."
Well I was 23 years old.
One of the things that I discovered
when I shaved for Buddy System was that
one of the things the
happens as you get older
is you gain weight right here.
The little bit of chin that I had
that I was able to kind of show.
Yeah.
When I weighed
like 185 pounds when I was 22 years old,
that's been filled in.
Right?
It's been, and I don't know.
If I was like, I'm gonna get super thin
and get super cut and then I'm gonna shave
and see what it looks like.
I'm not gonna do that but like,
that's another thing is that,
the turkey chin that is an inevitable part
of getting old.
Okay.
I'm not happy about that
but I have a beard to cover it up.
Yeah.
So when you get turkey chin.
Oh yeah.
You're gonna have
to make a decision.
Are you gonna grow a beard?
I'm gonna grow a,
I'm gonna grow a beard.
I think I am.
Yeah.
I just, I have always been a fan
of The Lord of the Rings Legolas
and not The Hobbit Legolas.
So I'd rather get a chicken chin
than whatever happened to his face.
He got a chiseled face,
I don't know what happened.
I don't wanna know but baby face Legolas
is the one that I'm gonna remain true to.
Wow I've never thought
about this difference.
His face was just totally different
and they did some CGI stuff too
because it was supposed to be,
he was supposed to be younger.
Yeah he was supposed to be younger.
But his face was like,
I mean Orlando Bloom's face bloomed.
You know what I'm talking about?
It's weird.
Oh okay.
But he, and it wasn't elvish anymore.
Last thing I'll say is
I definitely feel like
I've kind of transitioned
into a place where I needed more things
to be explained to me.
I actually, I saw that Matt
Carney tweeted recently
something about appreciating
the younger GMM writers
who always put notes in their scripts
that say, "Thank you for explaining
"this young reference to me."
All right, and even though we've got kids
and so we are a little
bit more in the know.
But not for long, they're
gonna be gone soon.
There is this being,
trying to be a part of
internet culture and you know,
we know that we're sort of YouTube dads
and we know that when we go on TikTok
people see us as these dad characters.
They don't see us as their peers
which is totally fine
and normal and natural.
But I just find myself hearing things
and needing someone to explain it to me
and feeling a little
bit more out of the loop
about more ideas,
concepts, slang, et cetera.
Yeah.
And that's only increasing.
I'm only going in the wrong direction
and then I was like.
But it's so good
for your brain to stay engaged.
The way that you're engaged in TikTok
is good for your brain.
It keeps you young and
yes it's a losing battle
and at a certain point
we're just not gonna care
and whatever the next TikTok is,
you probably won't care.
And then my version of that is,
okay I am going to try to appreciate
what is magical about Trippy Red's music.
You know?
I'm gonna try, I can connect
with Lincoln that way
but I've made a decision,
from a music standpoint
I should be able to,
I should be able to appreciate
what's happening now.
Yeah.
So that's the place
where I've decided to keep my mind young
and not allow myself to fart on something
I don't understand.
But also to be engaged as much as I can.
Not for clout, but just
for what it does for me.
Are you gonna change the way you talk?
That's another thing
I thought recently.
I cannot do that.
I can't, I've never.
I hear the new slang and I'm like,
I just can't do it.
Even hundred percent.
I cannot say, so many people, 100%.
That's not even new slang.
It's not even new slang.
That's like 75 slang.
75?
Like somebody's saying.
No it's not.
100%, I agree with that, I say that
and I've said that since
I was 20.
No.
No you haven't.
It has now become a social colloquialism
over the past five years.
Hunded, hunded, that's different.
100%.
Just conversationally,
when you agree with somebody saying, 100%
is something I can't even do that.
Okay, well that's.
I take issue with that
because I don't feel like
I've adopted any slang
and I say that.
That is slang.
It is slang.
But it's one that you
felt like you could adopt
because it's, it's not young
people slang exclusively.
It's actually, I think it's more of,
it might be our age slang.
But it's still something I can't do.
I'm using it as an example
of something I should be
able to but I just can't.
Well, but I don't know because.
And saying bro, that's.
I can't say, I cannot call anybody bro.
I can't do that.
Well bruh.
Or that.
Definitely.
Like there's so many of
them but I feel like I'm,
at this point I'm so, I'm so far behind
because at some point,
I've never wanted to,
oh you seem like you're talking that way
because you're trying to connect.
Yeah.
With somebody.
And so I don't think I should.
But the more that you don't do it,
and the older that you get,
it becomes that, then you
sound like an old person
and you don't even know it.
Yeah.
Like right now
it's still like borderline.
I can have a conversation with a teenager
and they'll just be like, "He's a dad.
"He's not youth."
But like 20 years from now,
if I'm talking exactly the
way that I am right now
which is most likely the case,
at that point I'll be using words
that the way you perceive
an old person who says like,
what do old people say
when something is great?
Well serendipitous.
I don't know, but so be it.
Like a grandfather.
So be it.
Yeah I'm accepting that.
Right, 100%.
All right, you got a rec?
I do, and I do think it's relevant
which mine are usually
not but this one is.
There was a documentary,
it was recommended to me
by a friend called
"Beauty is Embarrassing".
It's not a new documentary,
it's been out almost 10 years.
It's about an artist named Wayne White
who is the guy who did all the puppets
and stuff for "Pee-wee's Playhouse".
He was back in that era.
Okay.
Doing all that stuff.
He's a Southern boy that
we really relate to.
I mean he's older than us but,
a small town Southern guy who
kind of got out of the South
and went to the big city
and pursued this career
in entertainment.
But the story is really about how he has
continued to stay creatively engaged
and had these multiple career phases.
Where all of a sudden he just invented
a whole new thing that he was doing,
that he became known for.
And it's super inspiring to
see somebody so committed
to their own creative pursuit
in a way that's not related to
trying to be successful
in a conventional sense
but just following
their creative instincts
wherever they might lead.
Now for him the result has been
that it has been very rewarding
and commercially successful
but he's just a delightful guy.
It's a really awesome story.
Wayne White is his name again.
The documentary is Beauty is Embarrassing.
Okay #EarBiscuits.
We'll speak at you next week.
Let us know what you think.
If you're middle aged
or hope to be one day,
make us feel better about it.
To watch more Ear Biscuits
click on the playlist
on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon
to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.